hello there steve here again
today i'm also going to talk about
english common difficulties in english
i'm going to try to speak slowly
and i'm going to talk about verb tenses
now
you may have seen that um
after my video on monday where i spoke
about
i am bored and i am boring and so forth
i also did a video on the same subject
in japanese and had a discussion with
anna in spanish on the same subject
and tomorrow i'm going to do a
portuguese discussion with gabrielle
silva from brazil
we're going to talk about that and other
things
i don't know how useful they are
because i think it's better to listen
for any english learners out there to
listen to me in english
you can
import the youtube video with
closed captions with subtitles into link
as a lesson and work on these issues in
english
so
tenses are a major
difficulty for learners of english
there seem to be a lot of tenses in
english
however i must say that in learning
persian or greek not to mention spanish
and other romance languages they also
have a lot of tenses
so every language
says
you know is able to express the same
ideas and the same nuances but they do
it in different ways
so
with english tenses you have to get a
sense
of the meaning
and get a sense therefore of how certain
things are said you have to get used to
it
now you can read explanations about
tenses but you have to listen to enough
and read enough
in the language
so that
these ways of expressing ideas become
natural to you because they are not
natural in your own language you are
learning a different way of expressing
things but a few comments about
english
tenses first of all
many people struggle with the continuous
form
i am going i was going
i would have been going
so
first bit of advice is if in doubt use
the simple form
if in doubt don't say
i was living say i lived
instead of saying i am eating say i eat
because in many cases both are okay
and it sounds stranger to use
the continuous form
where it's not okay whereas in many
situations if you use the simple form
actually it's quite acceptable so when
in doubt use the simple form
so instead of saying
i was living in france for three years
you just say i lived in france for three
years
i am eating breakfast every day just say
i eat breakfast every day go for the
simple form that's the first bit of
advice okay the next thing is
when you see a phrase which contains
some
form of the verb some tense
that you feel you have trouble with
underline it save it see what other
words are there
so
for example
if it's say every day if you see the
word every day that can't have the
continuous form don't ask me for the
logic
but that's how it is so i eat breakfast
every day we simply don't say i am
eating breakfast every day
logically it's continuous why wouldn't
you say i am eating every day but we
don't say that we say i eat breakfast
every day so that
every day
or always
most of the time
is it means you'll have the simple
present okay
on the other hand if you see
you know
uh i was eating breakfast
when the phone rang
we wouldn't say i ate breakfast when the
phone rang
we might but mostly we would say i was
eating so that when that sort of when
something happened
suggests that it will be continuous
don't ask why i mean you can read all
the explanations of why
it may help you a little bit it's
probably useful thing to do if
particularly if you read the grammar
explanations in english that helps your
english but in the end you have to get
used to
the sort of environment the environment
what are the words that seem to trigger
trigger certain tenses
um
uh you know
and so i i don't want to go into more
examples i want to keep the video short
try
to uh get used to and therefore you have
to grab not just
that tense
but everything that surrounds the tense
and if you're on link
you can save these phrases and you can
tag them and then you can look at them
sort of
in a concentrated form and try to get a
sense
get a sense and we all struggle with
this uh in my russian i struggle with
certain things that are
in the russian language which don't
exist in english i have to develop a new
habit the explanations
are of marginal value i have to be
exposed to so much of the language that
these things start to become
natural i mean if i think of japanese
for example you know
i don't know any grammatical terms in
japanese i really don't
but if i say tabemas tabete mas
tabitemas is some kind of a continuous
form it's just something that i after a
while start to naturally say so
and one other thing i would add is you
have to want to acquire the new habit
you have to want to acquire it i
remember i once read a book called the
mind and the brain and one of the things
they talked about in there was people
who have obsessive compulsive behavior
people who feel they have to wash their
hands every five minutes
these people
who often are given medicine to cure
this compulsive behavior
this psychologist discovered that if he
was able to persuade this person that
there was a circuit there was something
happening in his brain
that didn't have to be him
that he had to want to have to recognize
that he he didn't have to have that
compulsive behavior that that is
something that's happening in his brain
that he can
want just through his his willpower can
want to stop okay now i don't want to
get carried away with the psychological
analysis here but
you have to say i want to develop new
language habits
i have to have these habits in order to
naturally use the language correctly
there is a system in every language and
that system
we can explain it but that doesn't
really do it for us we have to want to
develop these new habits we develop them
best through lots of exposure and using
the language but also because we want to
develop the habits we want to notice how
the language works and we want that to
become a new habit so that's my advice
on tenses and
i don't know if i'm gonna do these all
in different languages maybe it's best
that you take these lessons as an
opportunity to improve your english to
listen to read
and hopefully develop some new habits
bye for now